The last thing that we're going to take a look at in this course is a new type of control
that we haven't explored yet, and this is going to be the float control.
And we want to use it as a slider to make a simple open and close animation for our finger
controls.
So we're going to use this slider control and convert its translation values along
a single axis into rotation values for the finger controls.
And we'll do a simple bit of math to then multiply this value just to make sure that
it's given us some nice results.
And the main thing that we need to know going in is in what axis we want to rotate the fingers.
So in our case, this is going to be the Z axis, but we'll take a look at that in a moment.
So back inside the engine, let's first create our new float control.
So I'm just going to right click and come to new control here.
And in the details panel, we can change the value type of our control from Euler transform,
which is just a traditional control that you can transform with translation and rotation
and scale as well.
We're going to change that to a float.
And now you'll see that the control type changes inside the viewport here.
And when we move it, it sort of slides along this line that it's created.
So selecting that, I can only move in one axis.
Currently that is the X axis.
So if we wanted to change that, we could do with the primary axis here, change that to
Y and it will move only in the Y axis or Z and it will move only in the Z axis.
But the X axis works fine for us for now.
Now one thing you'll notice as well, we can't move this float control directly in the viewport.
So we'll have to create another control as its parent and then use that to move it.
So come back to create one more new control and we should probably name these.
So let's rename this slider parent and the actual float control will rename slider underscore
control.
Now we'll drop the slider control inside the slider parent.
And then this slider parent, since it's just a Euler transform control, we can actually
move that to wherever we'd like it to be.
So just for now, I'm just going to put it inside the, up around the waist between the
two hands because we're going to set this control up to make fists out of both hands.
So something I forgot to do there is actually set the offset transforms so that when we
compile it maintains its current location.
So we're going to choose set offset transform from current.
Now when we compile, that's where the slider parent stays.
And what I'm going to do is drop it inside the root control here so that anytime we move
our route, this slider is going to come with it.
And just so we don't get confused between the two controls, I'm actually going to set
the parent to not visible.
This means that whenever you use this in a sequence in the engine or whenever we're
previewing it in the viewport here, we can't actually see and interact with the slider
parent unless we make it visible again.
So that when we grab the slider control itself, we're not confusing what we're selecting.
So let's customize the look of the slider control a little bit.
So I'm just going to change the color to maybe like a purple kind of color.
And I'm going to change it to an arrow to solid.
And this is just to indicate the direction that the controller is going to move in.
And currently it's facing the wrong way.
So what we can do with this is come to our rotation channels here.
And in the Z, we'll put 90.
And in the X, I suspect is it minus 90?
Nope.
And I think it will be in the Y. So minus 90 in the Y.
There we go.
So now that when we grab our control, let's make it a little bit bigger as well actually.
Now that when you grab our control, we know in which direction it's going to move and
it just makes a little bit more sense visually.
Just as a quick tip, another way that we can actually adjust the position of this control,
or at least the rotation of it, is by holding control and pressing the full stop of the
period button.
That will then set us into the shape transform manipulating mode.
So if we wanted to just make sure that we were rotating in the correct direction and
not have to worry about using the actual physical sliders over here under the shape
transform, we could just do that in the shape transform manipulation mode.
So if you hold control and press period again, that will just exit that mode for us.
Now that we have the slider control looking how we want and positioned in the world where
we want, let's take a look at some of its details settings on the right hand side here
in the details panel and adjust some of the minimax settings because this line right here
at the moment is probably a little bit too long and if you were using this to animate,
it would feel probably quite cumbersome inside Sequencer.
So under the value heading here, we have some minimax settings.
Now you might find that this is actually kind of half hidden by default with the width of
this details panel.
So you can just drag that open a bit bigger and you'll be able to access minimax just
here.
Now you can see our maximum is set to 100 so I'm just going to bring that down to 20
and you can see in the viewport our line has become a lot shorter and this just means it's
going to be easier to manage and we don't need super super fine level of detail to go
all the way up to 100 units.
But you should adjust this value to whatever works best for your setup.
Now that the control is ready to go, let's make a start on the logic.
So we're going to set this up in a similar way to our alternate finger controls.
We're going to use a couple of get children nodes.
So if we search for get children, again we'll get two of these nodes and we're going to
look for our right hand control first, duplicate that with control D and then change that to
our left hand control.
And we're going to add these two together with an append as we did previously.
Again making sure that we tick recursive on each of these so that we find all of the children's
children and then we're going to pull off here and search for another four each node
because we're going to do some logic to each item in the array.
And next we want a set transform node because we're going to be setting the transform or
setting the rotation of these controls.
So if we right click search for set transform.
One thing that's important to change here is the space in which these transforms are
going to be made.
So we want to change it to local space.
We're currently set to global space.
And this is so that each control rotates around its local axis.
And under the item heading here I'm just going to change the type to control.
And this is more just for a bit of organization over anything else because when we connect
the elements to the item pin here, it doesn't do that.
I don't need to do that.
And next we need a set transform node to set the transforms of these controls.
So if we come across here, search for set transform and we're going to connect our element up
to the item pin here and then connect our executes.
One thing that's important to change on here, however, is the space that this node is functioning
in.
And we want to swap from global space to local space.
This is so that all the rotation happens around the local axis of each control.
So this is the logic for our finger controls.
We're finding the controls themselves.
We're running through each item in the array and then we're going to set the transform
as soon as we have the logic set up for the slider control.
The first thing we'll need is to bring our slider control into our rig graph and choose
get control.
And then we're going to be using the float value as our sort of translation input value
to drive the rotations of the finger controls.
So if we pull off float value and search for from Euler, what this does is it converts
the float value information, so that single transform information into rotation values.
If I just delete the conversion there, we don't need to convert this into all of our
rotation channels.
We just want to convert it into the Z rotation.
So I'm going to drag that into Z there and plug our result into the value pin here.
And then what we should see as I move this, if we connect the logic up first, just going
to add another sequence pin to hold S and left click.
What we should see as we move this control is that our finger bones or our finger controls
start to move, which is a great start.
But it's not quite right, so we need to do a little bit of maths to get this fixed.
Now the first thing you'll notice is our fingers are kind of rotating the wrong way.
I'll zoom in a little bit here.
So as we slide this slider over to the right, they're more extending than they are curling.
So we could fix this in one of two ways.
We could flip the value that's coming out of our float control, or on the actual control
max settings and min settings.
We could flip them the other way, so we could go from minus 20 to zero.
If I just compile that, we'll see that our control goes the other way now.
But our finger controls are curling instead of flexing.
Now something else we need to do as well is it feels like we need to increase how much they curl,
because they don't really curl enough for me.
So we could do this by just increasing the length of this line that we have for the float,
so coming to the minimum and making that number larger.
So we could go to minus 80 for example.
Or if we like the way it's set up currently, what we can do is multiply the value coming out of that float control.
By something like three, I think we found three works quite well here.
And we'll see that that just increases how much, or times is the rotation value by three essentially,
increases how much the finger controls curl.
Now the last thing we need to do here is just connect up our bones to our controls.
And we're going to do that in a similar way to how we were using the finger controls to find,
sorry, the finger bones to find our finger control names in previous setups.
But we'll do it in a slightly different way.
So this time we are searching for the hand controls rather than the hand bones.
So our names currently have underscore CTRL on the end.
And we can remove that instead of trying to add it.
So I'm just going to drag this out here to give us a little bit more space.
If I open the element pin here and come down to name, we can search for replace.
And under core, we'll get this replace node.
And now what we're going to search for, this is essentially a search and replace node.
What we're going to search for is underscore CTRL.
And we're going to replace it with none because we essentially want to remove it.
And then the next thing we're going to do is search for a set transform node.
Bring that over here.
And we want to get the transforms of our controls and set the transforms of our bones.
So I'm going to pull off the element pin here and search for get transform.
And that means for everything inside the array here, we're going to get the transform off.
And then I'm going to plug that into our set transform node here.
And for the children or the item of the transform here, I'm going to pop item open,
plug the name of our replace pin into the name of our transform pin.
And we want to make sure that the type is set to bones.
So it's searching for bones.
So once we connect this logic up and compile, what we should see is that our bones are now
being controlled by the joints. And this with this one control, we're able to make a fist or at least
drive the controls of the fingers.
And that's your setup. So we're searching for the hand controls.
We're adding them together inside a single array.
And then for each of those items, we are setting the controls rotation using the
the translation of the float control. And then we're going to use the same control names,
but just by removing underscore control to find our bone names.
And then we're going to use the transform of our controls
and set the transform of our bones.